peut-être le témoignage qui pourrait
emporter la vie des juges au procès de
derek chauvine l'ex officier de police
jugé pour la mort de georgia floyd et
notamment sa méthode controversée
arrestation une pression fatale ou pas
exercer sur le cou de la victime pendant
de très longues minutes il hier les
supérieurs de derek chauvine n'ont pas
épargné leurs ex employés estimez vous
donc que cette forme particulière de
pression si c'est comme ça que nous
l'appelons viol en réalité les règles du
département je suis entièrement d'accord
cela viole nos règles il faut que ce
soit objectivement raisonnable nous
devons prendre en compte les
informations sur les circonstances
la menace pour l'agent la menace pour
les autres et la gravité de la situation
donc ce n'est pas conforme à nos règles
ce n'est pas ce que nous enseignons et
cela ne doit pas être toléré témoignage
important alors que les policiers très
protégé syndicalement sont rarement
pointé du doigt aux états unis par leur
hiérarchie le chef des forces de l'ordre
de la ville de minneapolis avait le
lendemain d'un incident licencient les
agents de police incriminé dans la mort
de judge floyd et avait prononcé le mot
meurtre lundi l'homme ainsi insisté sur
les mots respect et dignité
concernant leurs rapports avec la
population georges de floyd soupçonné
d'avoir écoulé un faux billets de 20 $
l'afro américain âgé de 46 ans avait été
menotté puis plaqué au sol
lundi les regards étaient également
tournés sur le témoignage du corps
médical et le médecin des urgences ayant
constaté le décès des deux georges floyd
votre théorie principale concernant la
cause de l'arrêt cardiaque de monsieur
floyd était-elle alors une déficience en
oxygène c'était l'une des possibilités
les plus probables
j'estimais qu'à l'époque sur la base des
informations dont je disposais elle
était plus probable que les autres
possibilités et docteur y at il un autre
nom pour la mort par manque d'oxygène
la 6e' est un terme couramment utilisés
merci docteur pas d'autres questions
les avocats de derek schwyn eux n'ont
pas dérogé à leur ligne de défense
le décès de georges frêche serait lié à
une consommation excessive de drogues et
notamment un analgésique l'hypoxie le
manque d'oxygène au cerveau exact
certaines drogues peuvent provoquer une
hypoxie si vous êtes d'accord
en particulier le fentanyl et la
méthamphétamine
c'est possible une combinaison des deux
le médecin urgentiste a confié n'avoir
reçu aucune information sur le fait
qu'un officier de police est pratiqué un
massage cardiaque sur le lieu de
l'incident
ce qui a diminué de 10 à 15% par minute
les chances de survie de georgia flotte